hello everyone
welcome to my lecture
the limbic system
let's get started
in this lecture we're
going to cover the
basic anatomy and the
cellular circuitry
of the limbic system
the major important
structures are singular
gyrus hippocampal
formation and amygdala
so we are also going
to touch on different
kinds of memory
disorders as well as
other clinical syndromes
associated with limbic
system pathology
please be sure to see
the detailed objectives
in cpg as well as
the scholar rex break
for the complex
blueprint you can
see the information
that's highly
relevant to limbic
system is amnesia,
Wernicke-Korsakoff
encephalopathy,
learning disorders, and
symptoms related
to trauma
and stress like PTSD.
On the USMLE blueprint,
as usual, there are
normal processes and
abnormal processes.
So for normal processes,
we know limbic systems
are highly related
to emotional behavior
regulation and for
an abnormal processes
it's highly related to
anxiety disorders mood
disorders so very
important content here
the limbic system this
name coming from latin
limbus so limbus
means border which is
you can see here the
bordering between the
cerebrum cortex and
the diencephalon so you
can see the structure
here like a ring forming
the limbic system so
the limbic system is
a core it's a list of
structures that provide
very primitive or like
a fundamental human
type of feeling
emotional processing and
so it's regulating
the hypothalamus and
autonomic output and
these emotional regulation
structures are really
the composition is
under debate and we
have a big three so big
three meaning the three
biggest structures
that everybody agrees
upon so if you ask about
the limbic system
everybody would say these
three structures the
cingulate gyrus which
is here cingulate and
the hippocampus here
as well as amygdala so
these three structures
has always been
considered as a part of
limbic system and there
are a bunch of other
areas you can see here
long list and they're
also around this
borderline between the
cerebrum and the
diencephalon including part
of the hypothalamus you
can see here including
mammary body as well
as some thalamic
nuclei and part of the
prefrontal cortex as
well as orbital frontal
cortex so the frontal
cortex is also
processing some emotional
um personality related
emotional sensation
uh effective component
like how we feel
about ourselves as
well as the insula so
we haven't really
talked much about insula
you're going to talk
about it in the uh the
taste pathway so insula
is also part of the
like connecting very
well with the limbic
system but some think
these structures are part
of the limbic system
others may not agree
so but at least these
big three you need to
know they're part of
the limbic system we're
going to go through
most of these structures
one by one as you can
see here the limbic
system are connected
with a lot of systems
but overall they receive
the sensor information
from the body you
know like from the
sensory regions of the
somatic information or
reticular formation
comes into the limbic
structures they all
also receive information
sensory information from
the cortex and so all
these inputs being
summarized and to produce
one major output to
the hypothalamus So
through the hypothalamus,
it's going to regulate
our autonomic
functions to change the
functions of our body,
usually unconsciously.
The functions of the
limbic system can
be summarized very
nicely into five Fs.
So these five Fs are
feeding, fleeing,
fighting,
feeling, and ***.
So basically all
kinds of, you know,
conscious functions of
the cerebral cortex is
linked with the
unconscious autonomic
functions of the brainstem.
For example, here
you can see the Indiana
Jones, you know,
when the actor sees
the rattlesnake, you
can see the scared
expression on the face
and then this lady
obviously is angry
and then you know on
the right this is the
plurible sensation
during *** right so
all of these are
highly related to
the limbic system
function another
function is about the
memory storage and
retrieval so very
important for human
beings in the
literature sometimes you
can see a term
called limbic lobe so
this lobe usually
referring to the singular
gyrus over here
together with the
hippocampal gyrus as
well as the medial
of the frontal cortex
so these structures
are kind of forming
into this loop buried
very deep inside the
brain so you won't
be able to see it from
the exterior you kind
of have to slice the
brain open you know
at least from the
midline you know the
mid sagittal view you
will be able to see
this whole loop so
that is our limbic lobe
first let's talk about
the biggest structure
in the limbic system
the cingulate gyrus
as you can see here
this blue structure
pretty big cingulate
gyrus wrap around the
corpus callosum on
both sides and it's
really as acting as
a gateway between the
cerebral cortex and
the limbic system it
receives a lot of input
from the cortex and
thalamus and it projects
to back to the previous
cerebral cortex and
then also to the
hippocampus So we're
going to talk about the
circuitry later, and
the main function is
to really regulating
the emotional aspects
of the sensory
perception and movement.
There was an ancient
surgery called
the cingulatectomy,
which is to destroy
part of the cingulate
cortex to relieve
the severe anxiety
and depression.
as example you can
see here the anterior
cingulate cortex has been
destroyed bilaterally
by the surgeon so
it's a pretty brutal
surgery but it does uh
relieve the psychiatric
or the you know non
-sensory component of
the sensory information
processing another
example is to treat
intractable pain as you
can see here you know
when there is a single
otomy being performed
then you know the
patient have a quite
interesting sensation
so they can still feel
pain that meaning their
sensory pathway you
know from this let's
say peripheral to the
spinal cord all the
way up to our primary
somatosensory cortex
that pathway has been
intact so the patient
can still feel pain
but it doesn't bother
them anymore so that
meaning the unpleasantness
or affective component
of the pain is
gone so this meaning
you know the cingulate
cortex has a very
important role in terms of
linking that
emotional sensation
emotional feeling to the
sensory information
of our body
okay knowing what
we have known
so far let's look
at a patient's
case so this
patient initial ep
you can look at his
mr image and let's see
what is the lesion and
then what do you think
the symptoms of this
patient experiencing
So the lesion is
here. You can see if
you recognize
this, the location
is the medial
temporal lobe.
You know, really the
biggest landmark is
here, right? This is
our midbrain structures,
right? So the
medial temporal lobe
right at the, you know,
along the midline,
those two structures
has been damaged.
So what do you
think the symptoms
the patient should
be experiencing?
Okay, so the damaged
areas are having
amygdala and hippocampus
located at the
medial temporal lobe.
And so this patient
will suffer from very
profound amnesia.
So it turned out
this patient has a
****** simplex
virus infection. So
this type of
herpesvirus has a
special affinity to
the limbic cortex.
So for some reason,
it's, you know, the
hippocampal formation
as well as amygdala
has the most severe
vulnerability and
being damaged at
first. That's why this
patient suffered
from severe amnesia.
Now let's look at
the hippocampal
formation more closely.
as you can see
showing here the blue
region this is a
hippocampal formation
the name of the hippocampus
is actually latin
meaning horse a seahorse
you can see here
you know the shape of
the hippocampal formation
looks exactly like
a seahorse so very
identical that's where
the name comes from
so we talk about the
hippocampus interchangeably
with the hippocampal
formation even though
the hippocampal
formation is actually
composed of three major
structures including
the dented gyrus
hippocampus and subiculum so
they're all over here
but you know for our
level our purposes
we can use those two
interchangeably just
consider them as the same
the hippocampal
formation receives input
from the
interrhinocortex here you
can see It's part of
the perihippocampal
gyrus, very close
to the hippocampus.
And it sends
output through the
fornix, which, you
know, eventually
reached the diencephalon
hypothalamus.
We're going to talk
about it in more
details in the
following slides.
So in here the hippocampus
is in charge of
the spatial orientation
and what's interesting
is that only the
right hippocampus is
responsible for the
spatial orientation or
navigation. You can see
here when the London
taxi driver imagining
the driving around the
town, only the right
side of the hippocampus
light up this is a
more oxygen consumption
in this brain region
very interesting
lateralization
showing here the
detailed hippocampal
formation structure
as you can see you
know there are ca1
ca2 ca3 ca4 these four
subdivisions forming
hippocampus and you have
this you know forming
a c you know a letter
c shape and then the
dentate gyrus also
forming another c uh
which is the you know kind
of a backwards interlocked
with hippocampus
and then subiculum
is at the end of the
hippocampus that's uh
you know serving as a
major output structure
that's sending information
out through the uh
fornix and interrhino
cortex is right next
to subiculum sending
information into our
hippocampal formation
so you don't need to
remember all these detailed
structures i do
want to give your
impression you can see
here this is giant neuron
this is one neuron
that having a lot of
dendrites and axons kind
of you know it's one
axon but a lot of
dendrites that are
really submitting all
the information from all
over the places so
this type of parameter
cells you can imagine
takes a lot of energy
to synthesize analyzing
the information
right so that's why
they're very sensitive
very sensitive to
oxygen deprivation
within minutes the
cells of those parameter
cells would be dead
due to hypoxia. So this
area is very sensitive.
So just need to
remember this, not the
detailed structures.
The hippocampus,
as we mentioned,
with the subiculum
connecting with
the outside,
you know, sending the
fibers to fimbria and
then connect with
fornix so this is a
fornix we have this
entire way and the fornix
is almost like a
gymnast you can see that
the legs are the cruce
of the fornix kind
of thick right and
then you have the body
of the fornix kind of
curved back and then
you have the two arms
those are the columns
of the fornix. So this
structure, fornix,
you know, depicted
here too, is actually
from the medial portion
of the temporal lobe,
goes around this
diencephalon, and then,
you know, goes around
the thalamus at the
base of the lateral
ventricle, and then
comes down to the
mammillary body, you know,
all the way to the
diencephalon, the
hypothalamus structure,
make a big circle here
around the diencephalon.
See, it's almost
completely overlapping.
And this is just
another view showing
here with, you know,
this is our hippocampal
formation with the
hippocampus. It
looks like a seahorse
shape. And then you
have the thimbria
connecting with the
fornix. So these
are the legs of the
fornix. And then that's
a body and then comes
up to the two columns
of the fornix.
And what is
this structure?
This is called
anterior commissure.
So anterior commissure
is, you know,
kind of parallel
to the posterior
commissure, and then
parallel to the corpus
callosum. So
it's transforming
information between
the two hemispheres.
You can look at
different views of the
relative positions of
these large fibers.
So here, that's the
body of the fornix,
that's a column. So
here, you don't have
a continuous column
because of the slicing.
And this is our
corpus callosum. So
you can see that's
one connecting the two
hemispheres. This is
our anterior commissure
also connecting the
two hemispheres.
Temporal lobe epilepsy
are highly related to
the medial temporal
lobe like hippocampus
and the amygdala so
these structures are very
active you know during
our daily life they
have a lot of neurons
have lower threshold
to be excited excitable
that's why they're
more prone for epileptic
seizure the epilepsy
that involves temporal
lobe is called
complex partial seizures
or psychomotor seizures
the symptoms are
presented as abnormal
sensations in involuntary
movements such as
you know repeated chewing
swallowing smacking
and it also in involved
with some memory
loss and hallucinations
this is a very common
type of epilepsy
relatively hard to treat
okay speaking of
amygdala let's talk about
it so amygdala is a
latin name meaning
almond so the shape
of here you can see
down here at the
little blue nucleus
this is amygdala the
relative size of amygdala
is small compared
to the hippocampal
formation around it
and if you compare
to the giant cingulate
cortex this nucleus
is small right so
showing here on the
coronal sections
you can see amygdala
here at the medial
temporal lobe next to
the hippocampal
formation you can see the
squiggly structure
hippocampus right so
basically even
though it's a small
nucleus it actually
processing very strong
emotions such as fear
anger and pleasure
we're going to talk more
in the following slides
amygdala is very
important for emotion
regulations if you
remember the lab that we
learned amygdala is
underneath oncus and so
it's right at the most
medial aspect of the
temporal lobe and it's
a close to hippocampus
and the lateral
ventricle inferior horn.
The amygdala receives
a lot of inputs.
You can see here from
the sensory cortex,
from the other limbic
structures, from
the olfactory
bulb, and other
structures like
hypothalamus, brainstem.
You can see it also
gives out the output,
you know, to
everywhere, pretty much
all over the brain.
What I would like
you to remember is
this hypothalamus and
septal areas. So
those are two main
aspects of the
amygdala's output. So
basically because
amygdala mediating the
very strong feeling
like anger and fear,
you know that when we
are feeling scared,
you know watching a
horror movie your heart
start pounding right so
you feel that palpitation
or when you're angry
then your blood
pressure just goes up
you know without your
control so those are
all autonomic functions
being changed by the
emotion and so that's
through this gateway
of hypothalamus so
hypothalamus is a
main regulator for the
autonomic functions in
the body maintaining the
homeostasis the link
with the septal area
is related to the like
the reward pathway so
the septal area we're
going to cover more
in the future slides
so basically you know
when you have something
pleasant for example
you smell like a
fragrant perfume then you
feel happy and And, you
know, that pleasure,
that euphoria type of
feeling is mediated
by the amygdala kind of
receiving the factory
information and then
integrating that and
then give you that
good sense of the
pleasurement. So this is
a septal area mediated.
As we mentioned, it
drives the fear sensation
and it has a reciprocal
connections with
the thalamus, hypothalamus.
and it attaches
the emotional
significance to memories.
So basically,
whatever memory that
can associate with
emotional responses
is controlled
by the amygdala.
So, for example, you
smell the really nice
perfume that's being
used by a pretty lady
and you love it, then
that memory will link
with a very pleasant
feeling. So that emotional
significance linked
with the memories, the
emotional association
is made by amygdala.
I mentioned
about the perfume
specifically because
it's actually
very important
for olfactory
memory.
So, you know,
basically, you can tell
the odor, you know,
the stink odor versus
the fragrant odor
will produce different
emotional, like,
effective feeling,
right? So those are
mediated by amygdala.
Lesions to amygdala
bilaterally will
cause this classic
Kluver-Bussi syndrome.
So the Kluver
-Bussi syndrome is
basically
blunted emotional
response to all
kinds of stimuli.
For example, the person
become more placid,
you know, with decreased
aggressiveness,
and then also
psychiatric blindness so
that meaning you know
when you're supposed
to have a strong
emotion now it become
more docile you know
a example would be
monkeys approach snake
not really scared
but really you know
hey what are you doing
you know that kind
of thing and hyper
metamorphosis meaning
you know the visual
stimuli being considered
as new even though
they're not so
sometimes something like
novel object recognition
being impaired
there's also hyperorality
that means you
have you know like a
very strong tendency of
putting in something
inappropriate to your
mouth so like eating
pencils eating dirt
and there's also
hypersexuality so
loss that preference
to ****** partners
and also enterograde
amnesia. So
enterograde meaning
going forward.
So it's in contrast
with retrograde.
So enterograde
meaning the
new memories
cannot be formed.
So for example,
what you have eaten
in the morning,
you forgot, you
know, just can't
remember those
things that happens
very recently.
But the retrograde
amnesia would be
something like,
you know, what's
your own birthday,
What's your parents
name? You know,
things like that.
Those would be
retrograde amnesia.
So usually if you
remember our patient EP,
usually this is
caused by the loss
of hippocampus and
amygdala together.
So then the patient
would suffer very
severe deficit in
forming new memories.
so the Kluver-Bussi
syndrome is the lesion
or the reduction or
removal of amygdala
function now if the
amygdala is a hyperactive
it's also causing
trouble we all know that
soldiers a lot of times
suffering from PTSD
right post-traumatic
stress disorder coming
back from the battlefield
So the current
hypothesis is that
the PTSD is usually
characterized by the
aberrant amygdala activation
and also abnormal
functional connections
between the cortical
and limbic structures.
So this is mostly
associated with
hyperarousal and
hypervigilance to threat.
okay now we've finished
talking about the
big threes you know
the cingulate gyrus
hippocampal formation and
amygdala now let's talk
about the rest of
the limbic structures
the first one is orbital
frontal cortex so
it's located here shown
in this neon green
color so at the very
tip of the frontal lobe
it has a lot of the
reciprocal connections
with the rest of the
limbic system such as
the thalamus the dorsal
medial nucleus of the
thalamus and also
septal areas and uh you
know so this is at the
frontal lobe and uh
hypothalamic nuclei
so um the primary role
of the orbitofrontal
cortex is also processing
emotional sensations
and social context.
If you remember
the, you know, the
famous patient, the
Phoenix Gage, you know,
the prefrontal
cortex are really
controlling patient's
personality, then
this is part of the
prefrontal cortex.
and another important
function is this
secondary olfactory cortex
for smell. So in order
to differentiate
different odors and then
link the odors with
the different memories,
this orbitofrontal
cortex is also important.
Septal area, what
is a septal area?
So the septal
area is considered
including nucleus
accumbens and the
back nucleus of the
stria terminalis.
If you remember, the
stria terminalis is
the output structure
from amygdala to
the hypothalamus.
And so there are some
nuclei that are buried
within the stria
terminalis. It's called
the back nucleus.
And these structures
are closely,
anatomically, closely
next to each other. is
to have a very strong
emotional response,
mediating the
reward and learning.
So this is a very
important dopamine
pathway called the
mytholimbic pathway.
The destination is
at nucleus accumbens.
So the nucleus
accumbens has like
abundant dopaminergic
terminals there.
When we eat something
like ice cream or
chocolate, the
dopamine is released.
This is an important
area. The nucleus
accumbens is a
very important area
to mediate those
reward response.
And hypothalamus
is a very
important limbic
structure.
It has reciprocal
connections
with the amygdala.
and also linked
with a whole lot
of other limbic
structures too.
The major function
for hypothalamus
is to control autonomic
output and
endocrine responses,
as well as a
homeostasis. We're not
going to talk in
great details here
since you have a
special lecture by Dr.
Grubisic.
And you can really
learn all kinds
of nuclei that
hypothalamus are
controlling in
that lecture. An
important structure
that I'd like to mention
here in the
hypothalamus is called
mammillary bodies. So
the mammillary bodies,
if you recall from
our anatomy lab, is
very round at the very
end of the hypothalamus.
And this round
structure is actually
very important for
mediating the memory.
It's connecting with
this nucleus, with
the anterior nucleus
of the thalamus
through this long
track called the
mammothalamic track.
So it goes around the
thalamus and eventually
reach the anterior
nucleus of the
thalamus. This is a very
picture that's
related to, clinically
related to the Wernicke
-Korsakoff syndrome.
So look at here,
this is our stem.
You can read what's the
presentations of these,
and this is a lesion.
You can see the
mammary body has
all those holes,
right? So you have
degeneration of the
mammary body, and
thus the patients
would experience
all these symptoms.
Let's take a
closer look at the
Wernicke-Korsakoff
syndrome.
So, Wernicke-Korsakoff
syndrome is mainly
caused by vitamin
B1 deficiency. And
this happens a lot
in the alcoholics or
poor nutrition people.
So, the vitamin
B1 deficiency can
cause the Wernicke
encephalophysy or
Korsakoff psychosis. So
those are two different
diseases, or they
can be linked together
called Wernicke
-Korsakoff. So
basically, not only with
encephalopathy, but
also with psychosis.
And Wernicke has,
you know, kind
of a slightly less severe
symptoms like
confusion, ataxia,
nystagmus, and
ophthalmoplegia. and those
are you can call it a
can of beer problem you
know the alcoholics
have those problems
right so but when it
develops further when
the mammillary body is
degenerated then you
start to see the amnesia
and hallucinations
in the person so by
then it's a lot more
severe than just the
Wernicke encephalopathy.
So Wernicke
-Korsakoff, you
can see the damage here
and the mediothalamus.
So pretty strong,
pretty severe
damage to the
entire diencephalon.
And how are we
going to treat it?
Because the Wernicke
-Horsakoff syndromes
are due to the
vitamin B1 deficiency,
we could supplement the
vitamin B1 to the diet.
And if we intervene
that early enough,
it's usually reversible.
So prognosis is
pretty good. However,
if it's really
going into the
strong, like a severe
degeneration of the
mammillary body, then you
would not be able
to see the reversal.
You know, just like
the patient that
we see in the
previous slide that it
does not get complete
recovery from
that degeneration
of mandular body.
The earliest description
of the limbic
connection is called
the Papus circuit.
This discovery is
made by Dr. Pappas in
1937, so really
almost 100 years ago.
So this circuit
starts from
the hippocampus
arbitrarily.
And you can see it goes
to the hypothalamus
mammary bodies, anterior
thalamic nuclei,
cingulate gyrus,
and then comes
back to form
a full circle.
By now, you should
be able to tell
me what is the
major pathway from
hippocampus to the
mammular bodies.
If you remembered,
we talked about
that little
gymnast, you know,
with the arms
and legs, right?
The legs actually
connecting with the
hippocampus started
with the fimbria, that's
the major output from the
hippocampal formation,
and then merged into
the fornix, right?
That's the structure
that looks like
gymnasts. And from
there, you know, the arms
will reach the mammary
bodies at the very
bottom of the
hypothalamus. From the
hypothalamus, there is
a mammothalamic tract to
go up to the anterior
thalamic nuclei. And
then from that thalamic
nuclei goes all
the way up to the
cingulate gyrus through
the anterior limb of
the internal capsule.
From there, the
cingulate gyrus
connecting back
to the hippocampus
via this structure
called cingulum.
Here again, starting
from hippocampus,
fimbria, and fornix,
connecting the hippocampus
with the hypothalamus
mammillary body and
from here through the
mammothalamic tract
linked with the
anterior nucleus of the
thalamus and then from
this thalamic nuclei going
through the anterior
limb of the internal
capsule now reach the
cingulate gyrus and
then from the singular
gyrus through cingulum
comes back to the
hippocampal formation.
So this is the entire
pivot circuit. It is
important for episodic
memory consolidation.
And of course, you
know, the entire
limbic system
is important for
emotion processing
and memory.
Okay, let's look at
some clinical cases.
So here there is a
patient called HM. So
HM has this image.
Are you able to see
what's the lesion or
what's the deficit?
You can see the
enlarged BCD
images in these
three BCD.
So what's lacking
here is shown clearly.
The medial temporal
lobe is damaged,
right? So the medial
temporal lobe is
removed, this
patient, for treatment
of intractable
epilepsy or seizure.
And remember, we talked
about temporal lobe
epilepsy. So there
are some patients that
have repeated the
temporal lobe activation.
And, you know,
eventually they have to
be, you know, these
structures that's
always causing trouble
has to be removed.
And what's the
consequence of this?
So HM suffer
from very severe
anterior grade amnesia.
Anterior grade amnesia
means you cannot
form new memories.
So the very long
-term memory from,
you know, the old,
before the surgery
removal is intact.
Now, besides the
anterior grade amnesia,
what else do you
think HM experiences?
Think about what
else, you know,
besides the
hippocampus, what
other structures
is removed here?
turn out that HM
is having problems
with olfactory as
well. So it cannot
discriminate odors
anymore. This is because
the primary olfactory
cortex is located
here. It's called
the piriform cortex,
which includes the
interrhinal cortex
and amygdala. So
this is a primary
olfactory cortex,
processing the
different odors, you
know, differentiation
of different odors,
and also attach
those odors with
emotional responses.
Do you remember
the secondary
olfactory cortex we
just talked about?
It's orbital frontal
cortex, right? So
that's secondary. And
this primary olfactory
cortex is the main
structure that
differentiating and
putting the emotional
significance to these
odors. So without the
medial temporal lobe,
you would not be able
to have this primary
olfactory cortex. So
that's another major
loss besides amnesia.
You know, besides
the memory function,
also this patient,
HM, does not
have the olfactory
function.
And besides is that
also because of the
amygdala loss, the
person would not be
able to keep track
of his internal
state. Meaning, you
know, if you're hungry,
if you're, you know,
like a fatigue,
exhausted,
you know, thirsty,
all these different
states of your body,
the internal states
of the body is not
tracked by the amygdala
anymore. So those
are the more subtle
deficits, but also
having problems there.
One thing that's not
impacted, you know,
with this HM, so the
procedural memory
is actually maintained.
So procedural memory
is like, you know,
how to do things,
like how to, you know,
for example, this
Tower of Hanoi. So
this is, you know, you
have to move these
pieces to another bar,
you know, either
this bar or that bar.
And then try to maintain
still from the bottom
up, the different sizes
has to be in the
order. So from a large
piece to the small
piece. So this procedural
memory is still intact
in HM. So loss of the
medial temporal lobe
does not impact the
procedural memory. So
where does the procedure?
So clearly different
types of memory is
controlled by different
parts of the brain.
Let's go through
some basic
brain structures
that's related
to different
types of memories.
Memories can be
divided into explicit
memory or implicit
memory. Explicit memory
is like more clear like
what we are talking
about, events or
facts. And those are
the things that you
have very specific
information related to
this type of memory,
like which date
is my anniversary,
right? Something
like that.
Those are controlled
by the medial
temporal lobe and
medial diencephalon.
So if you recall,
we talked about the
hippocampus and the
amygdala, very important
for the formation
of explicit memory,
as well as the medial
diencephalon-like
mammillary body,
anterior nucleus of the
thalamus, right? So
those are the important
structures forming
explicit memory.
Implicit memory
is also called the
procedural memory.
So those memories
are not the traditional
meaning, you
know, classical
meaning of the memory
that we all think
about. For example,
you know, skills and
habits, you know,
like you can ride
a bike and then you
remember that even
10 years after you
don't ride a bike,
you can still do it.
Some others
like emotional
associations to, you
know, a condition,
something like maybe
not emotional, but
just conditioned
reflexes. For example,
if you are, you
know, doing something
like a fear conditioning
with animals.
We use that a lot in
the rat study or my
study. So you basically
give an electrical
shock to the animal's
foot when you pair
that with a bell sound,
bell ringing sound.
You know, the animal
frees with the
electrical shock,
right? So if you pair
that bell ringing
sound with this
electrical shock,
then every time you
have those two stimuli
coming together,
the rattle mouse
will freeze.
And then later
on, after repeated
training, after
this conditioning,
if you give just the
bell ring without
electrical shock, the
rattle mouse would
also freeze. So
this is the memory
that's formed with
emotional associations.
And some others,
like if you pair a
conditional stimulus with
unconditional stimulus
without any emotion
attached to it,
they're at different
brain regions. So for
the skills and habits,
the cerebellum and
motor cortex and striatum
are very important
for that type of
learning. For emotional
associations,
amygdala, and for other
condition reflexes,
the associations are
responsible by the
cerebellum activation.
So those are different
brain areas that
help informing different
types of memory.
And here we always
talk about something
like working memory
and long-term
memory. So the The
working memory is
controlled by the
frontal cortex, so that's
not hippocampal
formation related.
The frontal cortex
is helping with that
short memory that's
related to planning,
related to reasoning.
So those are more in
the frontal cortex. And
also for the long
-term memory. Long-term
memory is something like
a very long term that
you have already the
memory consolidated.
That's also hippocampal
independent,
so basically not related
to the hippocampus
anymore.
It's actually stored
at diffused areas of
the association cortices
in the neocortex.
So make sure you
remember what types of
memory is controlled by
what brain structures.
Now let's talk about
some memory disorders.
So there are
different types
of amnesia and
also a more severe
form, Alzheimer's
disease.
Those are all related
to the memory disorders.
Amnesia, we talked
about several different
kinds so far,
right? There are
vascular costs of the
amnesia, basically
the bilateral medial
temporal lobe damage
because they're
sensitive to hypoxia.
There's also trauma.
Trauma can be damaging
the mammary bodies
relatively easier.
and then also surgery,
right, to remove the
temporal lobe epilepsy,
the foci for the
epilepsy origin. And also
infections. We talked
about the ******
virus specifically
can attack the medial
temporal lobe and
produce damage there to
produce amnesia. And also
alcoholics can suffer
from vitamin B1
deficiency and hence
Wernicke-Korsakoff
syndrome. That's the damage
of the mammary bodies,
and mediothalamus.
So all of those damages
can cause amnesia.
And a more severe
case of Alzheimer's is
the degeneration
of the gray matter
everywhere, you know,
in the entire brain,
especially the
hippocampal atrophy. And
you can see here,
the ventricles are,
the lateral ventricles
are much enlarged.
And also the, you
know, the sulci becomes
really deep. This
is because of the
degeneration of the
gray matter. So you
have that gray matter
density reduction.
Neurochemically,
these are correlating
to severe decrease
of acetylcholin. So
acetylcholin is a
major neurotransmitter
related to the
neocortex functions. And
significant degeneration
of the acetylcholin
production from the
basal nucleus basal
forebrain and the
tegmental area too.
The treatment for this
can be acetylcholine
asteris inhibitor. So
acetylcholine is broken
down by the acetylcholine
asteris and if
you inhibit this enzyme
you can reduce the
broken down of the
acetylcholine and to raise
the synaptic concentration.
So this is one
way to reduce the
symptoms of Alzheimer's,
but it does not usually
reverse the degenerative
processing. So it
might be able to slow
down the deterioration
of the decline of the
cognition, but it's
not able to reverse
this degeneration in
the Alzheimer's neurons.
okay now this is our
time to test ourselves
and review what different
knowledge that we
have talked about in
this hour and this is
a matching the type
of memory so this side
is the type of memory
to the brain structures
that's maybe related
to this type of memory
keep in mind that
one structure may be
related to multiple memory
types, or one memory
types are responsible
by different brain
structures. So this is
not a one-to-one link.
Give yourself some
time to complete this.
Hope you've
got this right.
now let's take it
home test yourselves
now we talked about
you know a bunch
of limbic structures
here and are you
able to fill in the
blank what their major
functions are so
pause the slide now
and then try to fill
in the blank now
here's the answer
so of course
all the limbic
structures are
related to emotional
processing.
Remember, we
talked about the
five Fs, right?
But each structure
has its own
little emphasis.
So for example,
you know, medkala
related to fear
and affection.
So make sure you
go through these
again, you know, for each
structure, what
are their special,
unique emphasis
about the emotional
processing and
remember all of these.
okay that's all for
our lecture for limbic
structure and if you
have any questions make
sure you email me
here and if you have
any feedback make sure
you click on this link
and then send me some
comments or suggestions
thank you very much
for your attention